Facebook has been on fire lately
removing thousands of pages it
considered to be inauthentic and the
target of their latest campaign meddling
in India's upcoming elections as Indians
prepare to vote in the general election
for the 17th Lok Sabha Facebook and our
family of apps continue our efforts to
help make sure the elections are fair
and free from interference both foreign
and domestic it's almost two hundred and
fifty million users in the country
Facebook's regulation of political
content has a wide reach earlier this
month they removed over 700 pages marked
fake and although only 15 were promoting
the ruling party Prime Minister Modi
took a big hit and that's because those
dozen or so pages had almost two and a
half million more followers than the
rest and who's helped at Facebook and
lists to fight that election meddling
domestic and foreign an American think
tank called the Atlantic Council even
its own employees were surprised some
within our community may view this
partnership with skepticism we would
expect nothing less and encourage more
in fact a healthy skepticism is a vital
part of digital resilience but how
healthy is that skepticism really Indian
journalists Abijah Dyer Mitra lodged a
criminal complaint against Facebook
accusing the social network of waging a
war against India he claims the tech
giant is trying to interfere in the
internal process of the election at the
behest of foreign powers normal
employees are not empowered decisions in
San Francisco
particle police we have a cybersecurity
saying me hearty Election Commission and
the other one thisis sitting God knows
where the Atlantic Council receives
millions of dollars from the US State
Department NATO and Washington's allies
abroad could it be that some of that
foreign funding is finding its way into
a social media campaign against meddling
both domestic and foreign wife easily
the students in this you know I don't
even want to another conspiracy part of
their being manipulated by a fire to
fire and all of that the point is there
that accompany this is an Indian
election I think they basically mystical
we are not Europe we are not willing to
cede our serenity to other countries
like this to each other like this and I
think they made a big mistake donors I
intend to pursue this together
you